what's going on guys I want to talk to
you about something extremely important
today and when I say important I mean
historic this is huge
please listen if you've been watching my
show for a long time since I started two
years ago or you're a new subscriber you
know something about me I'm a YouTube
film critic that's what I do
and if you're a youtube film critic
yourself you've probably gotten a lot of
comments saying you're not a critic
you're not real you're just an online
blogger and that's all you have I know
I've done a few those comments those
times could be changing my buddies over
the schmoes know I did a podcast
recently with the editor-in-chief of
Rotten Tomatoes and when she said that
they were considering possibly looking
into YouTube film critics as a
legitimate means of film criticism to
post on their Rotten Tomatoes website
the fact of the matter is Studios rarely
take online video bloggers seriously and
it's coming to the point where it's
obvious that that is the future of
online criticism and in a lot of ways we
get way more traffic than someone who
has say a magazine article or a website
it's just it's truthful and it's coming
to the point where people are starting
to recognize the YouTube film critics
have an audience that there is a large
fan base and that we have something to
say I personally think that's incredibly
awesome it's what I've been wanting
since I started doing this just for
someone to be able to say yes you've got
what it takes your legitimate you are
working hard these screenings you drive
to 30 40 minutes away it's not for
nothing people like what you're doing
and people are noticing it's happening
people so what I would love for you to
do is to look at the link below look at
the podcast with the schmoes know listen
to it for real listen to it because it
affects all of us in an incredibly
awesome way also check out the what the
flick show the editor of Ron tomatoes is
on that show on YouTube I put his
Twitter below tweet him saying hey
that's awesome that you're possibly
considering that let him know that we
have something to say that we're not
just people with a camera that we truly
love movies but they were able to
articulate why we love movies well
thanks for watching guys I appreciate it
spread the word make a video about it
yourself post it on Facebook tweet it
all that stuff you know how it works let
people know that this is happening that
this is real and that it affects all of
us
good way as you know I'm Chris Tuchman
thanks for watching I'll see you very
soon this Saturday I'm seeing a sneak
preview of we bought a zoo other view of
that for you then